here we go okay so speaking of kevin
hart
i don't know why kevin hart sorry i'm
interrupt yet i don't know why he
entertains this so he feels like he has
to
talk to people about the backlash of his
special was this what happened a little
baby said not no
no no
getting older dating boys and he was on
like his press drunken but they're doing
it all through zoom
he was on the clubhouse where the women
were talking about that joke and he
kind of joked around saying like yeah
these are just things i observed and
i called three hoes to verify this is
whole like activity
i didn't call my daughter a hoe i'm
saying what she's doing is hoe-like
and a bunch of people took issue with
this and started saying that it's a
black issue
and he doesn't like black women and this
and that
and so he ended up going on to social
media onto his instagram page
and made like a minute long video
defending himself
let me is it's right here i don't get
why he does this i hate every time he
apology he had a hat on
how long are we going to pretend how
long we go
brendan has could talk to the side he's
always like this
i mean it's better than the ti where he
just placed it on his hat side
head side every issue is an apology or
like always he's like trying to tell you
why he did it he's always like us
all right guys look we gotta stop all
right stop with the false narrative
it's a false narrative of being created
if you were in the clubhouse and part of
the conversation
this wasn't about black women it wasn't
about me
going against black stop a question was
asked about
the joke about my daughter and and me
referencing my daughter having whole
like activity
i have an answer to it here's what it is
guys when i called my daughter a hoe
i'm saying what she did this whole like
activity i called three former hoes that
i knew and asked him
activity we had a conversation about it
a good back and forth
there was never a black woman and black
man
back never so stop with that false
narrative first and foremost
also understand guys there is no other
way to market or promote because we're
in a pandemic
i can't go and do the talk shows that i
once did or go out and do the public
stunts i have no other way to market and
promote
except to go viral i have to create
conversations
generate back and forth that's the
marketing and promotion
attached to my now special
it's common sense here guys marketing
promotion
that's why i was in clubhouse marketing
conversation hence it leads to streams
so if you haven't seen it go see it zero
[ __ ] getting streaming now
but stop with the false narratives and
the clickbait
and the back and forth there was no
comparison to barack and oprah the [ __ ]
that i'm seeing stop
stop it stop it
false narrative marketing promotion
conversation
zero [ __ ] given on netflix what shows
are you referring to
clubhouse what is that it's a uh radio
show
oh got it oh he said it on a radio show
yeah he was doing an
interview basically promoting his
special he's doing a bunch of them
and this is the one that gained traction
because yeah uh
that's a show with primary primarily
just women
got it okay yeah it is crazy how people
just
take something you [ __ ] saying you
can't say something like jokingly they
think they know exactly what the [ __ ]
you mean it's like
as a comic yeah it's not i mean you
could say whatever that bit was
hilarious man i loved it
how about that when i get off stage at
the lap factory
right away you go bro i figure out what
you look like i'm like what just run a
bunch of other comics i'm like what
you're like
you look like a rottweiler we gotta [ __ ]
together
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic son